دفعه لندن مسلسل ضمن السباق الرمضاني هذا
العام للكاتبه هبه مشاري حماده اللي كانت
عملت من قبل دفعه القاهره ودفعه بيروتوا
نجاح كبير دفعت لندن بيتكلم عن مجموعه من
الطلاب من مختلف الجنسيات الثمانينيات
يدرسوا في لندن وكل واحد منهم عنده افكاره
مبادئه وحلمه وطموحه ومن التناقضات اللي
بينهم بتنطلق احداث المسلسل اللي بيروي
حكايات حب وغيره وشوق للوطن والاهل وطبعا
مثل الموسمان الماضيين الجد المغاب عن
ردات الفعل على المسلسل ومن اول حلقاته
مكان غريب
اللي علينا واللي مو علينا كل شيء
ممكن تكون اي شيء لانك
ومن ضمن ابطال دفعت لندن الممثله السعوديه
ميلا الزهراني اللي بتلعب دور عسل الطالبه
السعوديه المثقفه صاحبه الشخصيه القويه
والمتعصبه لافكارها واللي طموحها لدراسه
الطب في لندن خلاها تعمل اتفاق مع ابن
عمها وتتزوجوا عشان تقدر تسافر ميلا مو بس
من نجمات دفعت لندن لكن السنه هذه كمان
يبدو سانتها فهي كمان وجهه اساسي من وجوه
العمل الدرامي الضخم سفر برلك واللي بتلعب
فيه دور هند صفر برلك هذا مسلسل بيجمع قصص
حب وحرب وماساه وبطوله وتضحيه واستقلال في
قالب تاريخي وبتدور احداثه قبل وخلال فتره
الحرب العالميه الاولى المسلسل هذا كان
اخر مشروع للمخرج الكبير الراحل حاتم علي
واللي كان بيشتغل عليه حتى ايام قليله من
وفاته واستلم اخراجه من بعده الليث حجو
صناع العمل ومشاركيه اهدوا لروحه للعمل
عبر حساباتها وقالت انه العمل الملحمه
الاضخم وانه عمل بروح الراحل حاتم علي
وتنضم الينا الفنانه ميلا الزهراني اهلا
فيكي معانا يا ميلا وكل عام وانت بالف خير
يا هلا وغلا يا ساره كل عام وانتم بخير
شهر مبارك على الجميع على الجميع ان شاء
الله يا رب علينا وعليك كمان ميلا السنه
ما شاء الله يعني عملين ضخمين فعلا يعني
دفعه لندن وسفر برلك كل احد بيتفرج بيقول
هدولي من اكبر انتاجات العام تعتقدي انهم
نزلوا مع بعض كويس لكي ولا لا شويه يعني
كنت تفضلي لو يكونوا متبعدين شوي
شوفي الموضوع يعني شوي قعدت اتكلم فيه
فعلا يعني كان مخوفني خاصه انه انعرض
مسلسل فقط ايضا قبل رمضان وانتهت الحلقه
الاخيره ليله رمضان فكان الموضوع شوي يخوف
بس لما فكرت فيها من ناحيه اخرى انا انا
من سنتين معرض لاي شيء تماما
فقلت لا فرصه يعني اتوقع انه جاء الوقت
المناسب انه الناس تشوفني الحلو في
الموضوع انه شخصيات الثلاثه تماما مختلفه
والمسلسلين فعلا قاعدين نعرضون ورا بعض
اوقاتهم بعد ورا بعض ولكن كان من ناحيه
ايجابيه لي انك قدرت ابين قديش شخصيتين
مختلفه وهذا الشيء يعني اعتقد انه ان شاء
الله يفيدني
الاثنين في الماضي بس انه مع ذلك ايوه
مختلفين انت سفر برلك بس اصلا خلينا كمان
يوضح زياده للجمهور انت اصلا مصورته من
قبل منتهيه منه من اول
صح من سنتين انا مصورته واخذ وقت يعني في
يعني عمل ضخم صراحه كان يحتاج الوقت هذا
وصادف انه ينعرض يعني في نفس الوقت
تقولي مثلا ايش اللي لفتك فيه انك تشاركي
في عمل من هذا النوع هل كان عندك لقاء مع
حاتم علي قبل رحيله مثلا تقدري تحكي لنا
اي تفاصيل يعني
للاسف لا الله يرحمه ويغفر له مكان ما
التقيت في المخرج العظيم الراحل حاتم علي
ولكن التقيت
اللي يدعمني وشجعني كثير والعمل صراحه من
اول ما تكلموا عنه انا رحت تجيب الكتب
وقريت عنه وكان عندي سبق يعني كان عندي
لمحه عنها كثير فحبيت انه يتكلم عن حقبه
تاريخيه فعلا مفقوده فعلا موثقه تاريخيا
فعلا نحتاج انه نعرف عنها كجيل او الاجيال
القادمه يحتاجون يعرفون التفاصيل الحقيقيه
والصحيحه عن عن هالفتره وعن الاحداث اللي
صارت فكنت جدا متشجع ان انا اشارك فيه
والحمد لله كنت محظوظه اني اكون وحده من
الممثلات اللي موجودين في العمل اذا بدي
انقلك على دفعه لندن دفعه لندن على العامل
يعني ضجه يعني مختلفه تماما طبعا هو عمل
جماهيري يمكن اكثر من سفر برلك من ناحيه
انه الناس من جوز باله لانه ما شاء الله
كلكم مجموعه كبيره موجودين في وفي جدل ومش
الكلام هذا كله كيف كنتي وحده من دفعه
لندن كيف تم اختيارك
كانت الشخصيه الكويتيه وبعدين تحولت
لشخصيه سعوديه الخط عجبني الخط مختلف الخط
يعني يتكلم عن عن بنت تبي تحقق احلامها بس
بالحقبه هذيك صعب الموضوع انها تسافر لندن
لوحدها وعندنا زواج دائما يقولون مربوطه
الولد عمه وزوجته من الصغار ففعلا كيف
قدرت يعني تستغل
الفكره هذه وانها فعلا تتزوجها عشان تسافر
وتدرس برا بس الاحداث يعني معقده الاحداث
فيها فيها كثير من الواقعيه فيها كثير من
من بنات انا اعرفهم شخصيا انه فعلا تزوج
ولد اولاد عمهم عشان لمجرد انهم يسافرون
او كان في اتفاق بينهم هم يعتبرونهم
اخوانهم
فصراحه عجبني الخط حسيته شوي مختلف حسيته
شوي
يتكلم عن عن اشياء حلوه يعني هبه مشاري
حماده طبعا الكاتبه المعروفه بنوجه لها
طبعا تحيه معروفه انه هي دائما عندها كثير
من الخط وط في اللي بتعملها يعني في
مسلسلاتها فعندنا مثلا هنا خط انتو لما مع
بعض في الشقه سواء انه كويتيات سعوديات مع
بعض وكذا في الخط القصه الايرانيه في خاصه
القصه العراقيه وما الى ذلك تعتقدي هذا
الشيء لانه الناس بينتقدوا كثره الشخصيات
في المسلسل في ناس عاجبهم بس في ناس
بينتقدوا انت ايش رايك في هذا الموضوع
اعتقد ان موهبه كاتب يعني الاستاذه هبه
مشاري يعني عندها القدره انها تكتب على
الخطوط هذه كلها في عمل واحد وما يفقد اي
خط حصه او اهميته هذا الشيء صراحه مو سهل
على اي كاتب بالعكس انا احييها انه انه
تقدر تسوي اعمال بالطريقه هذه مو دائما
الموضوع هذا يكون يعني سهل لانه لو
تلاحظين بعد ما يتابعون المسلسل كل الخط
له قصه المختلفه تماما كل خط له قضيه كل
خط وانها تنجمع في عمل واحد احنا في عصر
السرعه فنحتاج كذا نخلص
مسلسل
اكيد سمعت الكلام عن الجراه وما الجراه
يعني حتى انت شخصيتك بتذكر كلمات يعني
اعتبروها البعض جريئه كيف بتحسي شوفي احنا
حنسميها جريئه بس هم في ناس اعتبروها
خارجه قالوا لا تليق برمضان ولا النوت ليج
تنعرض على التلفزيون
بالنسبه لشخصيه عسل لا ابدا ما كان في اي
جراه في الحوارات وكنت انا يعني حريصه على
الموضوع هذا ما في مكان يتحمل اي جرعه
يعني الموضوعها جدا خطا اوريدي معقد فما
تحتاج اي شيء بالنسبه لبعض الكلمات انا
انا ما اشوف انها انا اشوف انه بنات يعني
شويه في واقعيه انا اشوف انهم بنات في شقه
طبيعي يعني انه يصير بينهم بس برضه اترك
الرد يعني لاصحاب الموضوع بس انا بالنسبه
لي يعني
ما اشوف انه
يعني انت طبعا لانك مشاركه اصلا في العمل
يعني بالتاكيد انه هذا يعني الشيء الاساس
فيه هبه مشاري حماده والمخرج طبعا ولكن
انتم الناس اللي بتكتب اساميكم على تويتر
جالسين ماسكين في اساميكم انتم انه
الحوارات هذه انتم كانكم بتقولوها
صحيح وخاصه انه هبه يعني الاشخاص اللي
يصرون دائما على انه ما يتغير الحوار وانه
يكون موجود مثل ما هو لانه تتعب في
الحوارات وتكتبها بعنايه تكتبها على
الشخصيه
ففعلا يعني احيانا يعني لازم يقولون نفس
الكلام بالضبط
ارجع اقول يعني انه ماني شايفه انه في اي
شيء بالعكس لو استمرون في المتابعه راح
يفهمون القصه راح يفهمون مبررات كثيره بس
المشاهد يعني ما يقدر يحكم من اول حلقات
يعني صح لا انا كمان يعني مثلا اذا الواحد
يطالع لمسيرتك يعني
ابتديتي باعمال وخلينا نقول كل مالك ما
شاء الله بترفع السقف على نفسك ترفعي
السقف يعني الان بتقدمي اعمال نوعيه معينه
عندك فيلم شاركتي فيه في مهرجان
من بطولتك يعني كانه ميلا عدد حساباتها
ولا ايش اللي صار ايش نقطه التحول
فعلا يعني الواحد يتعلم
مستحيل يعني الواحد تقريبا له خمس سنوات
مالي فتره كبيره بس اعتقد انها كانت كافيه
بالنسبه لي اعرف ايش اللي يناسبني اعرف
ايش
العمل اللي فعلا راح يكون راح ينتج بطريقه
صحيحه او راح يعني احيانا في ورق بس ينتج
بطريقه خاطئه الضحيه الممثل هنا بديت اعرف
هذه الاشياء وما زلت اتعلم يعني لسه توني
فاولات بس رغم كده وقعتي ضحيه لرامز
استراحه نشوف حلقه حنسمع جعير وصريخ يعني
والله بهذلني صدق يعني
يعني حرفيا ما توقعت لدرجه انه في في وقت
ما شفت كاميرات وعرفت انه مقلب بس ما
توقعت انه رامز اوكي بس كان نفسي اضربه
بصراحه يعني
لا ما ضربتين خلاص
كده بعدين يقولوا السعوديات ما يضربوا ما
ياخذوا حقهم يعني شوفي هو
اللي جاه بس يعني
بالضبط يعني لازم كده تكوني قويه في هذه
المواقف قوليلي يعني الان لو احد
اسمع يعني الان الناس حتقول لك كنتي عارفه
عن الموضوع وماخذه فلوس انت اللي كنت
عارفه ولا ماخذه فلوس ولا امي وراس بنتي
اني ما كنت ادري ولا نص البرنامج انا ما
كنت ادري لين عرفت انه مقلب البرنامج لين
لين عرفت انه رامز ما كنت اوكي بس انت
ماخذه فلوس انه الظهور في برنامج يعني
طبعا ايه يعني كبرنامج عادي مع كارلا حداد
على السيره انت ذكرتي الان بنتك الله يخلي
لك اياها تالا كثير ناس ينصدموا انه انت
عندك بنت يا ميلا خلينا نشوف صورتها كمان
انت في مره نزلتي فيديو معاها يعني ما شاء
الله بنتك عمرها 12 سنه
13 سنه داخله 14 ما شاء الله طيب بس يعني
تزوجتي صغيره ولا ايش صار ايه يعني تزوجت
على 19 اوكي خلاص الناس حسبوا عمرك دحين
الان انتهى الموضوع ايلان دائما اقول اصلا
ما عندي شيء خلاص دائما اقول بس تقولي
كمان انه موضوع الزواج بالنسبه لك مو
مناسب يعني خلاص انت مكتفيه بحياه الفن
الان وبنتك وكذا
احس انه بنتي وماما يعني
ملين علي حياتي وشغلي ما في وقت حتى ما حد
بيتحملني ما اتوقع في زوجي بيتحمل انه انا
ما في خلاص
ما شاء الله عليك يعني رائعه انت شخصيه
رائعه وما شاء الله عليك وجهك زي القمر
وكلك صراحه تجنني يعني وموهبه وكل شيء
معنى اسمك وهذا مو اسمك الحقيقي صح مميله
لا لا لا اسمي الحقيقي اسم فني يعني كنت
اشجع فريق وبعدين بتصل لحد ميلا
اوك حلو حلو الموضوع
اسمك الحقيقي هبه صح اسمي الحقيقي هبه طيب
شكرا لك وكل التوفيق وان شاء الله كل
رمضان وطول السنه تكسري الدنيا بكل اعمالك
كانت معنا الفنانه ميلا الزهراني شكرا لك